E aí
[Música]
a série A 61
o trabalho passeio É de longe a Bianca
tu faz aquele planejamento
Há sempre um barco como se fosse uma
aventura com são consertar Tang Organize
todos os recursos entendo como é que é
aquela viagem define-se como trajeto
deve ser por isso que eu amo a minha
profissão eu já vou compartilhar com
você só faz assim faz com a mentir na
minha jornada no programa Sid o Cid é um
programa de desenvolvimento de um
sistema de empreendedorismo estado de
Minas Gerais ele foi Fair 2013 onde a
gente transformar Belo Horizonte que é
considerado na época um Desert só fértil
um texto custo de vida dos grandes
centros em normal
a capital tá o estado que mais tem
universidades públicas em no Brasil só
entendia seus talentos por não ter com
essa sistema combustível deles status
o projeto dessa
a cultura mineira e criar densidade
local é claro registadas empresas de
base tecnológica era mas o potencial
adaptar muito maior e precisava colocar
Belo Horizonte no mapa de amêndoas
o programa Eles estiveram na desafios
mas eu trago dois status aqui que me
deram grandes lições é possível mudar o
sistema realizado pessoal atrair
empreendedores internacionais pronto
para ele é do Internacional vinho Brasil
para poder para poder iniciar as
atividades econômicas aqui ele precisa
comprovar um investimento de 150 mil
réis e Essa não é a verdade que Wesley
Safadão e predomínio de uma atividade de
interação é de integração e operação não
tem dinheiro e após um estudo minucioso
dos processos de vistos analisadores
você desenvolver um Conselho Nacional de
imigração um processo que auxilia na
facilitação aí não precisa liberação do
visto
a descoberta de vocês vão começar por
esses empreendedores aparece mais no
trabalho já está fazendo de mexer de
café mexer processo articuladores de
embaixadas do Brasil no mundo inteiro
não é algo simples e o segundo Grande
Desafio Foi um investimento nos status
uma aceleradora fator crucial de uma
aceleradora era investimento é dinheiro
mas um problema né é de público vem e a
gente transfere recurso público uma
pessoa física
Oi e aí foi a circular na Assembleia
Legislativa uma lei vai provável nele de
2013 e carente 1704 que permite o Estado
tem passageiro pela sua vida para sempre
agiu só para você ter sua projeto viável
você precisa aprovar uma lei e passando
o bastão força de vontade acreditar que
era possível estudar os mecanismos que
pessoal conseguiu e depois de oito anos
nos Gerais ainda é humano estava no
Brasil até o Alec Benjamin
Oi vó mada visto facilitado tudo pronto
hora de rodar o programa eles a equipe
BBB14 geraram feliz gerião duas rodadas
fizeram ver e então organizado mas legal
fazer noite não só a gente tava
internacional selecionar me atraíram
mais de 240 empreendedores que vieram
para Belo Horizonte de vivenciar a
cultura e tem várias vezes que ainda
estamos aqui mas aquele ano ano de 2014
então muito ocupado um ano de eleição
a mudança partidária
Ah e não houve a continuidade que aquele
comentário quando isso acontece a gente
estava no município até mesmo da
iniciativa privada isso é muito
e o que é mudança que muda a liderança
muda os dirigentes sua secretária por
diretrizes belas comportados ecossistema
é bom centrismos que fazem os projetos e
Sinara
Ah tá muito independente iniciativa
pública por quê que acontece de quatro
em quatro anos e aí embaixo Existe 15 o
sítio fechado ou eu uso de ver que a
cobertura do programa uma questão
político-partidária não não foi eu só
precisa gastar não foi pintado né é o
mais uma questão burocrática quero
morrer e vi gente que existia na época e
até machuca ele 15 mais um O que é
parceiro legal que ela com que deu o
convênio é que fez corrente ele dois
junto em reservas 2014 não existe uma
pessoa jurídica para fazer fechar para
fechar o renovar o contrato revólver E
aí então 2015 precisamos fechar fotos do
Sítio só que é é uma só recebe como é o
que vende
é mas enfim acontece assim qual foi o
programa e lembra muito bem contar tinha
pegado na parede filho diz que tá mano
só e a Frozen e essa plaquinha foi assim
ela ela transmitir a volta de tutela
elas uma repercussão internacional no
programa porque empreendedores o mundo
inteiro se manifestarem positivados isso
se manifestaram pela volta
Oi gente volta na descrição que foi a
força da comunidade mesmo sendo a
questão burocrática né autor do programa
sem a união EA cobrança da comunidade
talvez o problema se de nunca ter
voltado o velho começou a ser atacado
pela comunidade descartar de todas as
formas de Jesus
se você tem que trabalhar era a
financiadora do programa
e eu conhecia bem a novidade importada
ajudar a entender o que estava
acontecendo e resolver esse problema
o Roberto o de entender o que estava
acontecendo gostamos os empreendedores e
marcamos reunião com a turma nessa
reunião a gente pode fazer para eu
digito manter a gente sai de Las zonas
Más com compromisso de que daí dois
meses eu ia trazer uma resposta da volta
efetivo do
e depois você me ao Governador e
direcionou Rio Branco aceitaremos
trabalhar e aí ele me convidar para
subir então Jesus é
é convidado a moderar a curadoria de
empreendedorismo e inovação da arte
Fórum Empresarial de rosto o que
acontecer Horizonte de creme e aquele
ventre gente resolveu que evento seria
uma excelente oportunidade tem que
contar para todo mundo todo mundo mesmo
porque ela não tiver internacional da
volta do programa então a gente correu o
delicioso não tinha com quem são os dias
para a gente organizar tudo desde não
tinha ido não tinha dinheiro não tinha
nada mas a gente não podia perder a
oportunidade eu escutei o Pedro nessa
hora criança cola branca baseado em
experiências vividas em outros outras
jornadas é Altas Aventuras um excelente
chute convés também ter mas isso é
assumir isso é empreender é uma melhor
oportunidade se jogar de cabeça eu
estava com muito medo mas eu fico com
medo mesmo apresentando
o programa até mais páginas com São
Pedro Vale ganhamos a confiança EA
cooperação dos empregadores da nossa
eu descobri todos os pratos
se estiver também muito Zap e
a falta de gestão do conhecimento foi um
deles
e a gente chama de fogo formação é a
gente julgou pela ideia a gente usou ele
tá no grupo eu estou no Google para a
gente a gente procura no Google edital a
gente vai entender o que que era estava
a lutadores da equipe tinha sido
contaram teatrais mente mente a em use
no processo do bicho comentei com vocês
anteriormente esse a gente teve que ir
lá você gostava de integração de novo e
é uma viatura entender tudo novamente e
organizado é como se a gente tivesse
dirigir um caminhão para essa estrada
sem manual sem instrutor pela primeira
vez o segundo grande desafio é fazer com
financiamento da gente fica oscilando
programa grande ele representava muito
do secretário E além disso
desconhecimento dos processos e até
mesmo os pés dentro da temática fazer
com que a alta gestão questionação
trabalho dele havia folhas forte
dedicação essa mesma cobranças acertada
que muitas das vezes mais duas vagas que
vou te falar sabe eu pensei em desistir
várias
é mais um desses do seu beijo encarei e
seguimos ó a rodada três filhos foi a
minha primeira tá então a gente fez ela
veio com uma receita de bolo tudo que a
gente ouvindo é o sistema a gente foi
implementando Nossa temperada né a gente
faz a gente foi muito que tiver e a
gente trabalha no muita parte disso E aí
no fim da 3ª rodada a gente tinha a
gente tinha uma curva de aprendizado
muito grande e a gente entendeu que a
gente tinha a gente podia melhorar
apesar da gente não tiver muito pediu pé
de que um problema tinha voltado o
superior aos outros nessas primeiras
rodadas é mas a gente tinha mijado Rua
expressar considerava que a gente
poderia potencializar os resultados que
ter em interiorizando todas as editorias
o resultado aprendidos os pontos
críticos e reorganizam nesse momento a
gente tinha foi bem alinhado engajado de
aula assim também a gente não usava
contratar todas as tecnologias não tem
um monte de fornecedor a gente poder
envolver tudo eternamente trazer muita
economicidade projeto E aí uma outra
pesquisam a gente Tomou que era é feijão
a parceria com a Universidade Federal de
Minas Gerais a que a gente pudesse um
trabalho desenvolvemos metodologia
transformando toda tem conhecimento
Tácito que a gente tinha esse mesmo
a entregar a gente fotográfico para a
sociedade qualquer um pudesse pegar
aquele material e desenvolver as
metodologias você tinha né mas o
programa de aceleração Essa foi a
decisão mais animada mais empolgada
nessa jornada mas ela foi a mais cavar
loucura talvez tenha se lascar
e quando eu também precisam fazer tudo
internamente é
e eu tava falando no celular descarregou
e programa transformavam que as pessoas
viram as relações negócio Pede uma
verdadeira legal mas aí veio antes da
morte com meu pai né
as pessoas começam organismo
O que é a nossa vida não é uma moça que
aquela decisão do para mim de da 4ª
rodada significava que eu precisava me
jogar de corrupião folgar única e
exclusivamente no meu trabalho eu tava
preparando Aquilo tinha também mas
conhecimento do meu pai mudou tudo e a
minha família precisava de mim e eu não
consegui identificar
o decisões erradas eu fiz traudit no
terrário confiei eu não merecia não
tinha habilidades necessárias para
algumas coisas é sempre ver mas mesmo
como visto a direção que ela tava a
gente desenvolveu as metodologias a
gente cumpriu todos os prazos a gente
desenvolveu essa fase passa voando tem
várias Aí ele dá uma cor elétricos
incríveis de ao surgimento e a porta da
4ª rodada ela seria um resultados
melhores do que a preferência mas era
muito claro para mim que eu vou lava com
o dever cumprido tinha-me dedicado que
tinha como ídolo o meu papel e que tava
na hora já Navegar antes antes
o parceiro letra as eu lembro a opção
comecei uma nova jornada e
eu trabalhei alguns meses que eu
precisava trabalhar ele nossos projetos
de vida profissional que ter mexido
enfim o programa hoje para sua 6ª Rodada
é um novo mato não formato muito mas
eles vez mais bonito rodada mundo no
formato a gente fez é com aqui outra
questão de vocês e hoje ele tá
completamente diferente do modelo que
completamente é modificar e ele Muita
gente me pergunta o que que eu acho
respeito dessa mudança do programa Na
minha opinião o Cid tem que ser aquilo
que deve ser uma pessoa que ele seja
é mas para isso a população precisa
entender que o sítio é reflexo de um
ecossistema
ao vivo tava orgânico adaptado adaptável
Eu só não pode acabar
o e Elizabeth as necessidades que os
empregadores precisam de ser então
entender antes de ser o maior
contribuinte para que o nosso
ecossistema Senhor e um dos pilares mais
importantes para o desenvolvimento de um
ecossistema que o crescimento de uma
questão de credores estavam é existem
projetos em todos os níveis de
maturidade Então se já existe no nosso
ecossistema
os elementos que trabalham projeto de de
ação operação porque não o programa
começar atingir outras esferas que não
existe almoço talvez de quem sabe amanhã
ou se dizer um problema muito mais de 1
Bom dia integração ou conexão O que
exatamente um programa de sensibilização
ou ou em torno de instigar é ativar o
documento projeto de ser é uma evolução
assim como ecossistema e vai evoluindo e
é normal que isso que a gente tem algum
projeto adaptável e é isso E é isso que
eu acredito hoje né ao meio tá minha
jornada é muito mais e ganhou os barcos
e outros navios mais vendo ele navegando
junto com ele porque no mesmo
ecossistema mas o desejo Vida longa ao
coletivo
G1